In a recent episode of
"Curb Your Enthusiasm,"
Larry David holds up a pack of cigarettes.
Specifically, Morley cigarettes.
Now, let's rewind back to 1960
and the Alfred Hitchcock classic "Psycho."
Take a look at the cigarettes
the psychiatrist is smoking
in the final scene of the film.
Look familiar?
Morleys have appeared in
hundreds of TV shows and movies
throughout the last century,
in everything from "The
Twilight Zone" to "Seinfeld."
And, to be clear,
Morleys are not a real cigarette brand.
So, what exactly is going on here?
Is this some deep, secret
connected cinematic universe
that ties Norman Bates to George Costanza?
If you pay really close
attention to shows and movies,
you'll start to notice
many of the same objects
over and over again,
like this newspaper.
There are several fake brands
that cross over into other works,
including Acme, Oceanic
Air, and Heisler Beer.
But one of the most
reused brands is Morley.
Jonathan Kuntz: Morley
cigarettes is the most
prominent brand of fictional cigarettes
that has been used for the
past 60 years in films,
television shows, and video games.
Narrator: Jonathan Kuntz
says they come from
a company in Sun Valley, California.
Kuntz: The Earl Hays Press
is a 100-year-old prop house
that supplies fake-brand
props to Hollywood.
And they are the main
suppliers of Morley cigarettes.
Narrator: According to its website,
Earl Hays Press pretty
much sells fake everything,
from chips and beer to
magazines and license plates.
Morley's design is based
on the most popular
real cigarette brand in the United States,
Marlboro, with its signature
red and white packaging.
Commercial: Come to where the flavor is.
Come to Marlboro Country.
Narrator: Marlboros are
often nicknamed Marleys,
hence the fake name Morley.
Earl Hays Press sells Morleys
in a few different varieties,
including Morley Lights,
as you can see here.
But to understand why Morley
even exists in the first place,
we have to go back and take a look
at the love-hate relationship
between tobacco companies and Hollywood.
Granny: What's that?
Jed: Winston cigarettes.
Try one, Granny. They is first rate.
Narrator: In the 1950s,
you mostly had sponsors for TV and radio,
where the advertising agencies paid for
and produced the show.
The characters even
used the same products.
And many of these early advertisers were,
you guessed it,
tobacco companies.
"I Love Lucy" was famously
sponsored by Philip Morris,
so you would see brand
integrations like this.
Lucy: Have you tried a
Philip Morris lately?
Desi: You'll love 'em.
They're so smooth and mild,
and they taste so good.
Narrator: Movies were also
typically cross-promoted
with tobacco companies.
Here's Joan Crawford, for example,
smoking Chesterfield
cigarettes in a poster
promoting her film "Flamingo Road."
If a show wasn't sponsored,
it would use a fake brand instead,
since it wasn't getting
paid to show the real brand.
Enter Morley. This fake
brand can be traced
all the way back to
episodes of "Perry Mason"
and one of the most memorable
horror movies of all time,
"Psycho,"
although the box shows
an earlier white design
as opposed to the newer
red and white version.
Kuntz: And I think this
is what really started
the Morley cigarettes craze.
Narrator: Morleys popped up in TV shows
like "Naked City" and "The Twilight Zone,"
most famously "Nightmare at 20,000 Feet,"
with William Shatner lighting
up a Morley on a plane.
But Morleys weren't used as much
during the 1970s and 1980s.
Why?
For one, the 1970 Public
Health Cigarette Smoking Act
banned cigarette ads from
airing on television and radio.
This was part of a big push
to stop smoking in TV shows.
And the appearance of cigarettes on TV
decreased in general around this time
by about 70%.
Tobacco companies turned
to movies instead,
paying big bucks to have
their cigarettes appear
in popular films throughout the '80s.
So there wasn't much of a need
for fake brands like Morley
in movies either.
But this all changed again in 1998
with what's known as the
Master Settlement Agreement,
which banned tobacco advertising
in both films and TV,
paving the way for the fake
brand's triumphant return.
Kuntz: The real explosion
of Morley cigarettes
in popularity in pop culture
comes at the end of the
1990s in "The X-Files."
Scully: Well, you'll be interested to know
that Morley Tobacco has subpoenaed
all of our files of the case.
Narrator: In the show,
The Cigarette Smoking Man
is a villainous character
played by William Davis.
He famously smoked Morleys.
And the fake tobacco company
was actually incorporated
into the plot in the
episode called "Brand X,"
something you couldn't do
very easily with a real brand.
But more on that in a bit.
Following "The X-Files,"
Morley started showing up everywhere,
even in video games and music videos.
Kuntz: It has literally
appeared in hundreds
of movies and television shows.
Narrator: Here's George
smoking a pack in "Seinfeld."
And Chandler holding a pack
in an episode of "Friends."
They're also found in "Justified"
and the 2019 "Breaking
Bad" movie "El Camino."
Shows technically have the freedom
to show real brands these
days for historical realism,
as long as it's not a paid ad.
Don Draper: Lucky Strikes is toasted.
Narrator: So, why would they opt
for a made-up brand from the '60s?
Well, real brands are a big risk.
Kuntz: There are several reasons
why film and TV producers
would avoid using real brand
names without permission.
There is a little bit of legal jeopardy
if your product is used to kill somebody
or is defamed in any way.
You might be subject to lawsuits.
Narrator: A study found
that villains are the ones
who are typically depicted
smoking in films and TV.
And brands likely do not want their image
associated with criminals.
Apple, for instance, reportedly
doesn't let villains use
its products in movies.
Real products are typically
covered up or disguised
when used in shows or movies.
In the 1930s and '40s, the brand letters
on cars in films were carefully removed.
Kuntz: Hollywood was quite careful
to keep brand names out of their films.
They didn't want to be associated
with any particular product line,
and they didn't want to offend the people
that were using a rival product.
Narrator: So these days,
Morleys are mainly used
as the replacement brand,
an inside joke,
similar to those 555 phone numbers
and the Wilhelm scream.
[screams]
Kuntz: Morley cigarettes have become
almost like a meme on the web,
something where you can
kind of wink your eye
at the audience and say,
you know, "We know that you know
that this really a movie
or a television show,
and we're just kind of
playing with things."
Narrator: And just as there's a risk
associated with smoking real cigarettes,
there's a risk with Morleys as well.
Kuntz: The problem with the
popularity of Morley cigarettes
is that when you see it now
in a movie or in a television show,
it kind of pulls you out of the fiction.